c'est con c'est pas sympa ce qu'on fait
parce que les gens vous parlent alors là
moi je vais vous dire la vérité c'est
pas tout le cas de tous les clients de
bruges où vous jure françaises français
je n'ai pas triché j'ai gagné le burger
de la mort après j'ai triché bon
[Musique]
alors je vais vous faire une confidence
autant je regarde the voice avec une
assiduité franchement je suis peut-être
la française la plus assidue autant je
n'ai jamais regardé collante m sorry
d'ailleurs je force mon fils le plus
jeune parce que le plus grand c'est trop
tard vraiment je le force à regarder
avec moi je crois que c'est la dernière
saison que je vais pouvoir et encore on
s'est engueulé on a regardé samedi la
ddu verture de la saison on s'est
engueulé parce qu'il n'en peut plus quoi
mais je pourrais le punir pour qu'il
regarde je vous jure
[Musique]
alors je vous raconter une histoire
évidemment mes fils vraiment j'en aurais
parlé de à chaque réponse évidemment on
les aime beaucoup le psg on n'est pas
rigolo qui soutiennent le psg un jour ou
au ballon d'or j'ai un ami qui est très
bien placé qui vraiment m'offre le
privilège ultime parce que mon fils le
plus jeune on y dingue d'obtenir une
photo avec kilian est mbappé qui est
ultra sympa ultra smart franchement on
en fait 15 des photos à ce moment là il
ya son père à kilian qui est là qui me
voient qui me dit ah on pourrait faire
une photo tous les deux parce que son
car il a mon âge donc il connaît les
robins des bois donc moi je suis hyper
fier oui avec plaisir et on fait des
photos avec le père de killian et il ya
kilian qui regarde son père comme ça
c'est que vu la fille et regarde son
père et que l' obscénité j
du coup j'ai quasi le 06 sec il ya
pratiquement
[Musique]
alors oui plein de fois sauf le burger
de la mort mais ça c'est qu'on n'est pas
sain parce qu'on fait parce que les gens
vont pas me croire mais je vous jure sur
ma vie et j'ai parfois ils m'abordent
dans la région ils ont dit nous que tu
as triché pour le burger de la mort et
je vous jure que ça me blesse ce que moi
si j'ai gagné c'est que l'enjeu pour moi
est très important donc je me suis battu
pour gagner je vous jure sur la vie de
mes enfants que j'ai déjà cité 157 x
pendant cette interview je vous jure
françaises français je n'ai pas triché
j'ai gagné le burger de la mort après
j'ai triché pas un autre fois
[Musique]
elle l'a déjà dit non non je connais sa
doudoune heureuses je sais qu'elle est
aux enchères je sais que même moi je
pourrais pas me la payer donc c'est vous
dire
mais moi j'aime bien rihanna où j'ai de
la tendresse
[Musique]
ça dépend si vous feront très lentement
on dit pas est bousculée mais
ponctuellement sinon je n'ai pas de noms
mais j'ai pas le jeu non j'ai pas de
théorie là-dessus on a dit pas bousculés
et doubler ça dépend
non il n'y a rien fait non alors hier il
y avait une femme très très agile
normand s'est pas dit pas qu'elle était
agi c'est que ça soit elle était déjà
morte et il était à la caisse mais elle
attendait un peu derrière moi avons
imaginé me laisser passer ça c'est
différent mais si je suis par exemple à
5 mais alors là moi je vais vous dire la
vérité ce n'est pas tout le cas de tous
les clients de bruit imaginé il ya une
casse à 5 m une femme qui avance à 0,00
7 km heure vous vous avez trois bananes
franchement on peut aller vite posé
banane payer le temps qu'elles arrivent
et en fait on a doublé personnes faut
être concret pragmatique dans l'âge
voilà
[Musique]
pour moi ne pas comprendre le metaverse
et même le fait que ça m'angoisse pas ce
que je ne comprends pas c'est le signe
de la vieillesse donc j'ai eu
confirmation l'aleba la semaine dernière
que tu vois la saya j'étais une personne
âgée
ouais il ment pas le pain pour eux ça
paraît beaucoup plus concret que pour
moi ça me donne une crise d'angoissé
commun
moi j'ai des angoisses quand les choses
ne sont pas dites avec le non dit j'ai
une de l'angoissé avec certains silences
donc forcément les mondes parallèles
[Musique]
la france que je perçois comme forte
puissante un pays qui marche avec un
système hospitalier un système éducatif
une économie tout ça et alors
j'accueille mais j'accueille grandement
j'accueille largement et je suis fier
d'accueillir parce que je me rappelle
que c'est la terre des droits de l'homme
je me rappelle à quel point
l'idée des frontières elle peut en soi
être absurde c'est une ligne destinée
quelque part non après pour à la
déplacer mois présidente la question
migratoire sera très tôt tu rends
d'ailleurs j'en parlerai passer à la
question des droits migratoires
[Musique]
oui et je me suis même abonné à bruz
ticks alors je n'ai pas regardé depuis
longtemps pardon mais c'est vrai que
j'ai je me suis mis à regarder beaucoup
de films et la plateforme des césars
j'avais des retards en film français et
puis je suis revenu à pareille depuis
janvier il y avait des cinémas qui
avaient réouvert donc j'ai quitté les
plateformes pour les cinémas et prend le
cinéma arabe